okay let's talk about the attacks on
democracy that have been fomented by the
Republican Party we've seen Russian
interference in our elections and a lack
of willingness from Republicans to do a
damn thing about it we've seen voter
suppression tactics and fake stories
about voter fraud and three to five
million illegal votes and we've seen the
gutting of the Voting Rights Act even
really serious attacks on the democratic
institutions of the United States and on
democracy and voting itself over the
weekend a report from the Miami New
Times was published and it says that
there are a ton of uncounted ballots
from Florida which are just sitting in a
mail handling facility for miami-dade
County which is by the way a
consistently democratic voting county in
Florida the specific details are still
blurry it's not totally clear why the
ballots were just sitting at the mail
handling facility it's not clear exactly
when they were postmarked which would
determine whether they're eligible to be
counted or not it's unclear whether they
were delayed because the mag a bomber
was actually sent a pipe bomb through
this facility the facility was evacuated
and is that may be responsible for the
delay we don't know but what we do know
is that these ballots could conceivably
have impacted the Florida gubernatorial
race between Democratic candidate Andrew
Gilliam and Republican Ron De Santis
these held up ballots from a very blue
part of Florida could have impacted the
Senate race between Republican Rick
Scott and incumbent Democrat Bill Nelson
so as all this is going on Donald Trump
says that the counting of these ballots
is voter fraud he tries to be clever but
he actually sounds very ignorant on
Twitter when he says quote you mean they
are just now finding votes in Florida
and Georgia but the election was on
Tuesday let's blame the Russians and
demand an immediate apology from
President Putin there is no evidence
whatsoever
that these ballots were forged or that
any ballots were forged Donald Trump
here is lying without evidence about the
integrity of our elections this is far
more dangerous than lying about the
number of people that attended his
inauguration these are lies meant to
give people false beliefs about the
integrity of one of the most important
democratic systems we have in the
country
that of voting and it wasn't just Trump
because then Sean Hannity on Fox News
interviews the Republican candidate Rick
Scott who is also Florida governor and
Hannity says someone should be in jail
for the ballot counting and if you're
watching this clip you'll notice that
Governor Rick Scott nods agreeing with
Hannity yes someone should be in jail
for counting people's ballots take a
look at this I've never seen anything
like this in my life
it is obviously corrupt obviously laws
were broken obviously their shenanigans
here I believe you and senator Rubio are
100% correct we will follow this every
single second of every day now yeah
because the people of Florida deserve
their just vote which they got and you
won this race hands down and this is a
this is a disgrace that they get to do
this election an election out somebody
needs to go to jail here if this keeps
happening you keep violating the law you
don't respond every other County
responds someone needs to go to jail
says Sean Hannity and Rick Scott just
nods so what do they claim is so wrong
with what's going on well they're saying
that finding these ballots is the scam
that once the Democrats realize they
lost these two races in Florida they
found these bogus fake fraudulent
ballots don't you think that if anyone
was actually planning to turn the
election with the bags full of fake
paper ballots they would have figured
out a way Pat to get those ballots in
before Election Day since usually
ballots are only
did before Election Day like every
allegation of voter fraud from the right
assumes everybody is stupid they claim
that people are swinging elections by
doing in-person voter fraud that
individuals are showing up at polling
places and voting twice or voting as
dead people or as people that aren't
actually them that would be such a
stupid way to steal an election and
likewise the idea that Democrats planted
countless fake paper ballots enough to
swing the election but they were stupid
enough to wait until after the election
was over to claim that those ballots
exist you've got to be incredibly
incompetent at trying to steal elections
if this is what you're doing yeah it's a
totally fair argument to say that it's
Monday we shouldn't be still counting
votes that were cast from last Tuesday I
mean we should just know the results
within 24 hours or so of the election
that's all well and good because I think
it can undermine their confidence in our
electoral system but what's not justice
justifiable is to say that well these
votes are coming in later so therefore
we just have to usurp the will of the
people and that these boats are just not
gonna get counted that's not the right
way out of this yes and there are very
clear rules about the postmark dates and
all sorts of other stuff like we can
very easily figure this thing out and
that's actually I want to talk to the
reasonable people in the audience for a
second if you are reasonable you
probably have the view that we should be
able to put political disagreements
aside and just work together and figure
out a simple way to make sure that
there's a fair and equal standard so
that everybody who is legally able to
vote and votes is sure that their vote
is counted and that nobody is scared
away from voting legally and you would
be right we should be able to do that
the reason we can't is that one party
benefits from a lower voter turnout
that's the Republican Party that's why
we can't fix it because one party and
one political movement the American
right wing they don't want higher
turnout it's bad for their candidates
it's in one party's favor for everybody
to vote and it's in the other party's
favor for people not to vote voting
itself is now partisan
and we're really screwed if we can't
figure that out and solve that problem
and and unfortunately I'm scared we
can't because the incentives are really
clear and the stakes are too high the
right can't allow everybody to vote
because they will get crushed and that's
why we have this situation today's
program is made possible in part by zip
recruiter there are a whole bunch of job
sites out there that send you a ton of
the wrong resumes or make you wait for
the exact right person to apply to your
job none of that is smart what is smart
is going to zip recruiter dot-com slash
Pakman which doesn't depend on
candidates finding you it finds the
candidates for you they use a powerful
matching technology which scans through
thousands of resumes it identifies
people with the right skills and the
right education and experience for the
job you're looking to fill and then it
invites them to apply so that you very
quickly get qualified candidates no more
sorting through the wrong resumes normal
waiting for the right people to apply
and this is why zip recruiters rated
number one by employers in the United
States this is from Trustpilot for
hiring sites with a thousand or more
reviews and right now our viewers our
listeners can try zip recruiter for free
at sip recruiter dot-com / Pakman that's
zip recruiter dot-com /pa KMA n it's the
smartest way to hire one more time
zip recruiter dot-com / Pakman